tous les déplacements du domicile sont
interdits sauf dérogation respecter des
distances entre chaque personne au
dessus du marché de cosne-sur-loire le
message se répète un drone muni d'une
enceintes diffusent les consignes de
prévention une présence bien acceptée
par les clients ce matin c'est surtout
d'entendre de ce qu'ils nous disent deux
parce que sinon
on nous rabâche pas les oreilles avec ça
il ya un moment donné ça sera pas
difficile et très bien voir beaucoup de
gens qui respectent pas les consignes je
trouve que les gens sont quand même
relativement indisciplinés donc je
trouve que les contrôles et le drone
s'est très très bien aux commandes de
l'engin des gendarmes en période de
confinement le drone est un outil utile
en complément des contrôles
d'attestation c'est efficace quand vous
êtes sur une place où on a un petit peu
de personnes qui doivent converger à
l'entrée d'un supermarché par exemple
donc là oui c'est efficace parce qu'il
permet un rassemblement de rappeler les
mêmes
les mêmes consignes un peu plus tard à
pouilly-sur-loire nouvelle mission pour
les pilotes
cette fois pas de message mais un survol
des environs pour vérifier que l'
isolement et respectés s'ils ont repéré
par exemple des gens qui se promènent
sur le bord de loire on a envoyé une
équipe la balle et les contrôles et les
invite à rentrer chez eux
prévention et surveillance pour faire en
sorte que chacun reste chez soi au
maximum le temps de l'épidémie ceux qui
ne respectent pas les consignes s'expose
à une amende de 135 euros
dans la nièvre près de 170 personnes ont
été verbalisées par les gendarmes depuis
le début du confinement